the United Nations Secretary General
says he's deeply disappointed by
Russia's withdrawal from the Black Sea
grain deal he says it's a Lifeline for
Global Food security the agreement
guarantees the safe passage of food from
the Black Sea to many parts of the world
our diplomatic editor James Bays reports
now from the U.N in New York
until the last moment the U.N Secretary
General had been trying to persuade
Russia to stay in the deal but President
Putin didn't even bother to reply to his
latest letter as he addressed reporters
his mood was Grim I deeply regret the
decision by the Russian Federation to
terminate the implementation of the
Black Sea initiative
including the withdrawal of Russian
security guarantees for navigation in
the Northwestern part of the Black Sea
these initiative has ensured the safe
passage of over 32 million metric tones
of food commodities from Ukrainian ports
inside the security Council western
countries were United in their
condemnation of Russia let us be clear
Russia's actions are taking food out of
the mouths of the poorest people across
Africa
the Middle East and Latin America and
now with announcement that it will
withdraw from the Black Sea grain
initiative Moscow is threatening even
more people more children with
starvation
Russia decided not to attend the meeting
at foreign minister level instead
sending its Deputy Ambassador he said
the deal was terminated but added this
the Russian Federation will stand ready
to consider its resumption only when
concrete results are achieved rather
than promises and assurances from
Western capitals Ukraine's foreign
minister dimitro kaleba told me there
are different views here at the UN about
whether the deal is completely dead
there are two schools of thought now
I can conclude that from the
conversation I've had I have had some
are
far less optimistic and others are
slightly more optimistic I'm told that
during his meeting with the UN Secretary
General Mr kaleba raised a suggestion by
his boss president zielinski that
perhaps the deal could continue operated
by Ukraine Tokyo and the UN without the
participation of Russia senior U.N
officials though are very doubtful about
that they say that no ship company or
insurance company would want to risk
their vessel coming under Russian attack
James Bay's Al Jazeera at the United
Nations
well let's bring in Russell cerda who
joins us live now from Istanbul Russell
James was just saying that there are two
schools of thought on if this deal is
dead it does seem that the Turkish side
though is hopeful that it can be held
together what do you make of the
Diplomatic efforts
indeed the Turkish style side seal
hopeful that this deal can be held
together just yesterday president
everyone right ahead of flying to Saudi
Arabia after Russia's decision has said
that he's still hopeful that this deal
can't work and he said the President
Putin of Russia he said he believes that
he wants to continue this humanitarian
Corridor through the balaxia and he says
that the Diplomatic efforts are going to
continue and the foreign Ministers of
two countries are going to meet so today
we have seen a phone call between the
Turkish foreign minister harkan fidan
and the Russian foreign minister lavrov
and after that there has been a
statement released and according to the
statements that say that the both
foreign ministers have discussed the
ways to explore new ways for the Russian
grain to be exported through a road that
is not susceptible to keep or Western
sabotage so from this statement what you
understand is that now they're the
Russia and Turkey Turkey they're trying
trying to create a different a new
parallel agreement so the first
agreement between turkey United Nations
and Ukraine that will allow the
Ukrainian green to be exported through
the Black Sea without participation of
Russia and the parallel road is going to
be between turkey and Russia that is
going to secure Russian grains to be
exported to the international market so
of course how they are going to secure
these roads and whether the Western
shank sanctions are still going to
remain as an obstacle or not this is not
clear at this moment but we know that
the Diplomatic affords are underway to
create two parallel roads one of them
started carrying Russian grain and the
other carrying Ukrainian grains so
president erdogan the day of tomorrow he
is going to be back in the country and
he says that once he's back in the
country he is going to have tolls with
the president uh putting off Russia and
based on that we will see whether this
diplomatic Force are going to produce
any concrete result well speaking of
which Russell anchor is one of the rare
NATO is it still has good times with
Moscow are these recent developments
particularly Russia's decision to
actually pull out of the deal affecting
that relationship
indeed turkey and Russia has very much
delicate relations now just recently we
have seen that President zielinski of
Ukraine has visited turkey and took his
explicitly prisoner don't explicitly
announce his support for Ukraine's
membership to Nato and on the top of
that he has also given six uh a senior
as of commanders to zelenski and they
flew to to to to to to Ukraine so this
has of course caused reactions from
Moscow and Moscow says that turkey has
violated the deal according to the deal
they say this as of commanders were
supposed to stay in Turkey till the war
is concluded and just two days after
that president was in Lithuania
attending the NATO Summit and he has
given the green light to civilian's
accession to Nato so right after that
now we have seen that Russia pulled out
from this green deal which is quite
important for turkey politically and
economically so now both sides are
meticulously careful not to deteriorate
relations because they are having very
sophisticated and multi-layered
relations in the East Mediterranean and
Libya in Syria in caucuses in Balkans
and in in Biloxi so that's why there's a
lot at stake from both sides however we
can say that the tension is gradually
increasing between the two capitals but
whether it's going to reach to a point
to be a rupture or not it's not clear
yet
there with all the latest for us from
Istanbul thank you Russell well let's
now go to Julia chapovalova she joins us
with the view from Moscow Julia the
International Community as we know has
overwhelmingly condemned Russia's
decision to leave the deal but Moscow
feels that its side has just not been
upheld
well Dmitry peskov Kremlin spokesman has
revealed Kiev uses the maritime area
allocated for the implementation of the
grain deal for military purposes he
didn't elaborate on details that we can
say the work on the deal continues here
despite it has been terminated by Russia
according to peskov after withdrawing
from the green deal Russia is ready to
replace the Ukrainian grain with its own
and Supply countries in need with it for
free as for Russia's supplies of grain
to Africa they will be discussed at the
highest level at the forthcoming Russia
Africa Forum in Saint Petersburg at the
end of July while the leaders of Russian
and Turkish diplomacy as it was
mentioned the Russian and Turkish
foreign ministers discussed options for
supplying grain to the country's most in
need plus they discussed the situation
around Ukraine it's interesting though
but President Putin is not planning
contacts with Turkish president erdogan
according to his press secretary of
peskov even though earlier of course
were heard from the Turkish president
himself that he was planning to to meet
with President Putin in Turkey in August
so basically the green deal dominates
the political as well as media sphere a
big green deal agenda here so it's being
discussed quite widely Julia there were
also denials that pulling out of the
grain deal was in response to the attack
that we saw on the Kirch Bridge linking
Russia to Crimea but I see the defense
Ministry has said that there has now
actually been other retaliation
yeah indeed the last night's strikes
with high Precision weapons on poor
infrastructure facilities in the
Ukrainian city of Adesa are the
retaliation strikes for the Crimean
kirchbridge that's what we've heard from
dmitra best call Kremlin spokesman and
the Russian defense Ministry indeed
actually said the same calling the night
missile attacks on Adesa and Nika live a
retaliation strike and according to the
ministry the strike was delivered on the
facilities where terrorist attacks were
allegedly prepared against Russia and as
a result all the is Strike Ukrainian
fuel storage facilities were destroyed
as well as unmanned boats which were
allegedly supposed to be used against
Russia so all that is Accord according
to the defense Ministry of course and as
we remember after the latest courage
Bridge attack President Putin promised a
response without specifying the what
kind of response it would be he just
said that the Russian Ministry of
Defense Was preparing their proposed how
to respond and also according to the
Kremlin the authorities are now
preparing their proposals how to improve
the security on the Crimean Kurds Bridge
there for us with the view from Moscow
thank you Julia